[Music]
who doesn't know the story of Winnie the
Pooh the question is do you know the
real one stay tuned to find out more
about the pretty disturbing story of the
real Winnie the Pooh don't forget to hit
that notification bell to never miss
another video and be sure to check out
our community section for even more fun
now let's check out the real story of
Winnie the Pooh the first story the
truth is there are two disturbing Winnie
the Pooh stories out there
one is the author's family's story and
the other is the actual story which
we'll talk about in just a little bit
hey Mel the man that wrote the beloved
Winnie the Pooh books created the fairy
tale world based on his son stuffed
animals you can actually see what
Christopher's toys looks like in real
life which is pretty amazing the
inspiration came at an extremely
difficult time during the world war but
many don't realize that his story is
actually quite an unfortunate one
despite the very fortunate success of
Winnie the Pooh books Milne served as an
officer in both world wars and it was
quite a miracle these books even exists
considering everything he went through
unfortunately Milne suffered from a
post-traumatic stress order which made
him moved to a quiet and peaceful area
just outside of London UK Milne later
found passion and writing and got
inspired by his sons Christopher Robin
stuffed animals one of those animals was
a teddy bear called Edward hop you
expected the name winning didn't you
we'll talk more about that in the second
part of this video Christopher Robin
later had his own very much beloved
character in the popular Winnie the Pooh
books and became somewhat of an icon in
the literary world but this seemed to
only bring more trouble as he got
relentlessly teased by his peers despite
the fact that Christopher's relationship
with his father improved when his father
decided to stop writing the books he
revealed his past was quite troubled in
a rare interview he stated that his
father's creation of Winnie the Pooh
books left him with nothing but the
empty Fame of being his son the
popularity of the books put an immense
restraint on Christopher's relationship
with his father and he stated that his
parents just didn't know how to take
care of kids in fact Christopher was
raised by his nanny and practically
lived with her in a nursery on the top
floor of the house he
after Winnie the Pooh books came to an
end Christopher estranged himself from
his parents in order to find his true
identity for the longest time he
despised Winnie the Pooh books and even
refused to accept any money from its
profits it seems that his childhood fame
as the Christopher Robin character put a
lot of restraint on his family as he
watched his father pay more attention to
the books than himself
Christopher passed away regretting the
470 thousand word long books
overshadowed the rest of his life you
can find out more about the family's
life story in a movie called goodbye
Christopher Robin while Winnie the Pooh
might come with tons of beautiful and
inspiring quotes it seems like the books
brought many hardships to the family
that struggled to deal with Fame the
second story that was the unfortunate
story of the restraint the books put on
the author's family but wait there's
more so we now know we've the Pooh
characters were inspired by Christopher
Robin's stuffed animal collection one of
those stuffed animals was known as
Winnipeg which was actually inspired by
a real-life Fair Winnipeg aka Winnie was
a Canadian bear it was bought for twenty
dollars by Harry the lieutenant's
Winnie's mother's life ended with a
hunter's bullets after being bought when
he quickly became the unofficial mascot
of the young soldiers regiment and yes
in case you're wondering when he is
actually a female bear and she actually
fought in the First World War
well sort of Harry actually hid winnie
on a ship when he was shipped out to
England to fight she didn't actually
fight in the war itself but she was
there as a mascot to boost morale just
like many other animals after realizing
that when you really shouldn't fight in
the war Harry made the ultimate decision
and took Winnie to the London Zoo he
asked them to take care of her while he
went and fought in the war he intended
on coming back to her after the war was
over but after seeing that Winnie was
being well taken care of at the zoo he
decided to leave her there
and that's when Winnie first met
Christopher Robin a a Milne
the author of Winnie the Pooh books used
to take young Christopher to the zoo and
Winnie was his favorite animal so even
though Winnie the Pooh is a kind
character and always comes with a life
lesson and plenty of quotes the real
Winnie actually had a painful past first
her mother passed away which resulted in
her participating in war and eventually
being taken
the zoo but even the real version of
Winnie was just as friendly as the
literary version we need befriended the
lieutenant and she befriended the boy
and his father who technically
introduced her to the entire world
that's pretty remarkable isn't it you
can actually find the lieutenant's diary
entry stating exactly when he bought
Winnie for $20 it was August 24 1914
Wendi stayed at the London Zoo and lived
for over 20 years which is remarkably
long for a black bear she was the only
bear that the zoo trusted with kids
Christopher was even able to cuddle and
play with her after Winnie's passing the
zoo made sure she's not forgotten even
though her character will forever live
in a literary form the duo also paid a
tribute to this remarkable bear London
Zoo actually holds a statue of Winnie
and lieutenant Harry holding hands as
well as another statue of just Winnie
the bear which part of this story was
the most surprising
did you know Winnie was a real-life heir
or that the success of Winnie the Pooh
brought an unfortunate restraint on the
author's family come let us know what
you think in the comments and that's it
for our video thanks for watching see
you next time
[Music]